I'm so excited to be talking to y'all
today um what has been your favorite
part of this show that y'all have
together uh what is your favorite part
of working on the projects with clients
specifically that's a very loaded
question yeah you
said what do you love about working on
the show what do you love about working
on the show clients let me we're still
going to answer all of it answer
it let me say this so before married to
real estate it felt like even you know
on my previous shows I was going to
work now it's just work comes to us if
that makes sense but it doesn't feel
like it because I'm with my family all
the time they're actually seeing you
guys are seeing what we do every day as
a business as a thriving couple as a mom
and dad with kids and how we balance the
juggling Act of being in business
together as well and so this has become
very much it's become fun it's become
cathartic as well it's authentically us
right I mean you wake up every day you
get to do something you love right
something you're passionate about with
the person that you are passionate with
and passionate about Wednesdays except
something about
Wednesday that's that hump
[Music]
day but you know again you're doing
something you love with the person you
love um you get to be creative you get
to put smiles on people's faces
sometimes when it's all done but through
the process it's different story but for
me what comes to mind right now in this
moment is the fact that we think of well
when I think about our fans which we're
calling them our fam now right fam we
get to inspire and allow them to see us
in a different light that they get
inspired by you know when the young kids
come up to to me and say I was watching
your show with my mom and man I see
myself in you that when I'm on set I'm
like no we got to do this because
Somebody's Watching in X Y and Z so for
me it's about inspiring the folks that
are watching
us amazing beautiful one of those three
questions you had I don't know that
answered everything that that was great
that was great for me I mean I love and
it's so nice to hear yall talk about
because that family aspect of your show
is what makes it so interesting in
compar to everything else on HGTV right
now like it's I love seeing y'all's
family Dynamic I love seeing the renewal
of season 3 the little treat that was so
cute she's adorable your kids are so
great so cute um how you mentioned the
balance uh aspect I'm sure y'all get
asked this a lot but I want to hear from
y'all uh the balancing of the family
life and being husband and wife and
working together you froze you froze for
a minute
question uh so I I was saying I know
y'all hear questions probably about
balance a lot but I would love to hear
from y'all about balancing working
together working uh being parents
together having all of that being
incorporated into the show what are what
are your tips and tricks how do you uh
thrive in that I was goingon to say
survive but I think Thrive is
better uh you know we say this a lot and
we stand on it the only way any of this
is going to work is if we work as a unit
meaning we can't just be adults we can't
just be parents we can't just be
partners we got to continue to like each
other and love each other so everything
else you know takes place properly and
the way we do that is continue dating
continue communicating you know it's not
just about work work work work work to
show show show show show that's actually
secondary otherwise it won't work we um
have an amazing support system for our
children you know that's that's that
that gives us peace so when we're here
on the road or we're in the middle of
filming we got the aunties the uncles
the cousins making sure the kids are all
right gives you a peace of mind I you
know when he said that what immediately
came to mind is how we're able to be
here even today in New York when we were
leaving both of our kids fell sick and I
went straight into Mommy Mode we got the
humidifiers the cool M we got the
Medicine we got you know I'm putting
onions on their feet to pull the
sickness out I mean I'm in full Mommy
Mode worried like crazy and we're
supposed to be getting on a plane and I
I said we're going to have to cancel it
we can't be there because the kids got
to come first and the aunties his mama
everybody comes to the house and kicks
us
out and they're like we got this and
Mike said they raised us and kept us
alive right they're fine they got it and
so we got on the plane and I was just in
full mommy panic mode just worried like
crazy tell me to the minute what's
happening um but but our village
our family our true they they got us
covered and I think when people watch
our show what we want them to get
because we don't take this for granted
at all you could be watching anything
what we want them to get is that it is
about the family unit and we consider
you our family which is why we're
opening our doors and I promise you
before we even did season one Mike and I
said well if we're opening our house to
everyone and we are allowing them to see
our children and get get to know our
relationship and everything we what is
the what's the Line in the Sand going to
be and we said if it starts to affect
our marriage or our children negatively
as much as we're loving the journey we
got to cut it and so far we are full
throttle because if anything we get
embraced I mean we go to
Costco we go to Costco and people run up
to us but it's not like oh let me snap a
pic let me it's girl let me tell you the
recipe because when you were in the
kitchen I saw you cooking that all
wrong or or they run up to Mike and say
I got this leak what are you doing on
Tuesday can you come over because they
they feel that familiar with us and
that's why we we say fam now are not
fans fams yeah that makes so much sense
and I love that you have this massive
Village sorry were you gonna say
something Mike to add on to that no no
no no you might have it it may have
sounded like that because she started
talking FY is a one second
delay good to know thank you
so you spoke of family um are we going
to be seeing any Viola concerts I had to
ask I love Viola and I read that that's
in your I love the idea of black kids
playing classical music so will we get
to hear any yes so Kendall uh she's
actually joined her school orchestra and
Viola Viola Viola we've been arguing
about is it Viola viol okay so she she
that was her instrument of choice and
obviously our what we want our kids to
do is if you choose something stick to
it work on it perfect it don't hop in
and hop out and be one foot in one foot
out of everything however when the sound
started you know that feeling when your
kids are just practicing on the
instrument and they don't know
oh
God it was like nails on CH for it so
that I mean it's funny it's funny so you
you we can't give too much away but you
you'll see some um some strings being
clocked here
in but I must say this we couldn't CT
her we actually just went to one of her
concerts she has progressed very much so
a lot yeah amazing that that's wonderful
to hear and it is Viola my partner is a
a classical musician who plays viola so
can confirm
Viola that's a person versus what I was
saying though it's it could be Viola no
but some one person somewhere somehow
start saying Viola and everybody just
said VI but I think just like it's
worst sauce not wor would you let this
girl
go no it's okay it's okay I was I was
with you on the journey I was with you
on the journey um so speaking of the
third season it's super exciting I know
you can't give too much away but um what
are you hoping your G your fam will gain
from this
season it's really that when you when
you have a dream and a goal in mind
cancel the negative selft talk because
part of this journey to season as well
um is watching us open our business
bring it all under a One-Stop shop for
Real Estate renovation design and Home
Furnishings we are in go road now our
doors are open we brought it all full
circle but um it's it was years of just
trying to make it happen in the way that
we saw it happening and you I think the
truth is there's there's no one way to
success but what you got to do is stay
inspired positive and have positive
selft talk all the time and so we show
you that journey of me being a mom
waking up with a list of things that I
want to do for myself and by the end of
the day I've accomplished absolutely
none of them because you're pulled in a
million different but can you imagine
how many women feel like that every day
because they're taking care of their
kids or their husbands and clients and a
million different things but I wanted
people to know I stuck to my goals we
stuck to our goals as a family and
everything we said we were going to do
we did it because we had positive selft
talk we were accountable to one another
we wanted to be that good example for
our kids to show them again we're not
we're not just going to talk the talk
we're GNA walk the walk we tell you if
you um decide to Endeavor on something
you got to see it through we had to
Endeavor on something and see it all the
way through not just talk about it um
but but how many people feel that way
you know that life just kind of be
lifing life be lifing I'm gonna get a
t-shirt that say that and and then you
know your all your goals start to seem
further and further away so hopefully
what everybody gets from this season is
inspiration and motivation to get up and
make it happen not tomorrow but today
yeah and I'm hoping people get inspired
and motivated to not over stuff the
dishwasher what I mean by that is I
don't like you to see that there's a lot
of debates of us talking about how you
properly load a
dishwasher and how to make sure it's
comfortable in your house with the
temperature what you keep your
temperature at in the house when it's
it's cold I live I live in Texas so it's
it's never it's
AC well well right now the heat is on so
722 what you will see is someone who
refuses to live with with someone with
an OCD
personality not so so we G we G we gonna
spark a lot of debates in households
that's what we're gonna do this
season I love it well I know people are
your fam I'm a fam now officially um
we're so excited to see the show come
out on the 28th married to real estate
on December 28th perfect family show for
the holidays that's what it's all
about to
you thank you I love my present can't
wait to open it on the 28th you go all
right well thank you so much share your
gift too make sure you tell aun aunties
and uncles okay oh it will be shared it
will be shared I got a big old family
then tell go on social media and say
leave Egypt alone at least that D on
dishwasher Got Loaded thank you it got
loaded let me
tell got somebody to tell that to
too well I I thank you so much again for
your time and I appreciate you taking uh
your time to tell us about what we have
to look forward to today uh this coming
happy holidays bye thank you you
too